on May 1st 1969 Fred Rogers testified
before the Senate subcommittee on
Communications he was there to raise $20
million for Public Broadcasting and in
his way was Senator John pastori pastori
was known as a tough guy who wielded
great power as the chairman of
subcommittee and enjoyed grilling TV
Executives watch how Mr Rogers melts his
heart and gets the money that he needs
it's a great lesson for all of us enjoy
in Boston they prefer Fred Rogers to
Superman I spy Batman Thunderbird even
Perry Mason and MV Griffin Mr Rogers
estimated
99,00 homes with Kids 2 to 11 represents
a third of that audience the show
reaches an estimated 113,000 homes for
an overall rating of four and a share of
10 Mr Rogers is produced by Pittsburgh W
QED
TV now Mr Rogers is certainly one of the
best things that's ever happened to
public television and his peab body
award is Testament to that fact we in
public television are proud of Fred
Rogers and I'm proud to present Mr
Rogers to you now all right Rogers you
got the
[Music]
floor Senator
pastori this is a philosophical
statement and would take about 10
minutes to read so I'll not do that uh
one of the first things that a child
learns in a healthy family is trust and
I trust what you have said that you will
read this it's very important to me I
care deeply about
children my first children will it make
you happy if you read
it I'd just like to talk about it if
sorry my first Children's Program was on
WQ 15 years ago AG go and its budget was
$30 now with the help of the Sears robu
foundation and National educational
television as well as all of the
Affiliated stations each station pays to
show our program it's a unique kind of
funding in educational
television with this help now our
program has a budget of 6,000
it may sound like quite a difference but
$6,000 pays for less than two minutes of
cartoons two minutes of
animated what I sometimes say
bombardment I'm very much concerned as I
know you are about what's being
delivered to our children in this
country and I've worked in the field of
child development for 6 years now trying
to understand the inner needs of
children we deal with such things
as as the inner drama of
childhood we don't have to bop somebody
over the head to make him to to make
drama on the screen we deal with such
things as getting a
haircut or the feelings about brothers
and sisters and the kind of Ang that
arises in simple family
situations and we speak to it
constructively how long a program is it
it's a half hour every
day most channels schedule it in the in
the noon time as well as in the
evening uh WEA here has scheduled it in
the late afternoon could we get a copy
of this so that we can see it maybe not
today but I'd like to see the program
I'd like like very much for you to see
i' like to see the program itself or any
one of them you see we we made a 100
programs for E the Eastern educational
Network and then when the money ran out
people in Boston and Pittsburgh and
Chicago all came to the four and said
we've got to have more of this
neighborhood expression of care and this
is
what this is what I give I give an
expression of care every day to each
child to help him realize that he is
unique I end the program by saying
you've made this day a special day by
just your being you there's no person in
the whole world like you and I like you
just the way you are and I feel that if
we in public television can
only make it clear that feelings are
mentionable and and manageable we will
have done a great service for mental
health uh I think that it's much more
dramatic that two men could be working
out their feelings of
anger much more dramatic than showing
something of
gunfire I'm constantly concerned about
what our children are
seeing and for 15 years I have tried in
this country and Canada to present what
I feel is a meaningful expression of
care do you narrate it I'm the host yes
and I do all the puppets and I write all
the music and I write all the script
well I'm supposed to be a pretty tough
guy and this the first time I've had
goosebumps for the last two
days well I'm grateful not only for your
Goosebumps but for your interest in in
our kind of
communication could I tell you the words
of one one of the songs which I feel is
very important
yes this has to do with that good
feeling of control which I feel that the
children need to know is there and it
starts out what do you do with the mad
that you feel and that first line came
straight from a child I work with
children doing puppets in in very
personal communication with small groups
what do you do with the mad that you
feel when you feel so mad you could bite
when the whole wide world seems oh so
wrong and nothing you do seems very
right what do you do do you punch a bag
do you pound some clay or some dough do
you round up friends for a game of tag
or see how fast you go it's great to be
able to stop when you've planned a thing
that's wrong and be able to do something
else instead dead and think this song I
can stop when I want to can stop when I
wish can stop stop stop anytime and what
a good feeling to feel like this and
know that the feeling is really mine
know that there's something deep inside
that helps us become what we can for a
girl can be someday a lady and a boy can
be someday a man I think it's one Wonder
F I think it's
wonderful looks like you just earned the
$20
million because you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and and I love
you so as a special celebration if you
put a hasht believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there to
see Jim Ron's last public interview
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there Jim ran is one of
the fathers of personal development he
was Tony robbins's personal mentor and
influenced other greats like Jack
Canfield Mark Victor Hansen and Brian
Tracy